une usine de liquéfaction de gaz naturel
au port de saguenay l'idée avait été
écartée l'an dernier mais l'est-elle
vraiment que d'un code chez elle
le gouvernement legault a assuré à
maintes reprises que gnl québec n'était
plus dans des cartons or selon nos
informations le ministre de l'économie
pierre fitzgibbon y est toujours ouvert
il aurait fait savoir à ottawa qu'après
les élections provinciales québec serait
prêt à reconsidérer le projet d'abord ya
pas de changement aujourd'hui le chef de
la caq est catégorique ou fermé la porte
à tout jamais à ce projet là c'est fermé
un gazoduc de près de 780 km aurait
effectivement acheminer du gaz naturel
du nord-est de l'ontario jusqu'à l'
usine de saguenay la majorité des partis
s'y opposent également et accuse
françois legault de manquer de
transparence après avoir dit qu'il ne
ferait pas être en train de négocier en
catimini quelque chose qui n'a pas sa
place face au logo ses convictions en
environnement on peut pas compter là
dessus évidemment qu'on est content ce
projet là qu'on veut se tourner vers des
énergies renouvelables plus des secteurs
d'avenir de passage à saguenay justement
le chef du parti conservateur lui s'est
prononcé en faveur du projet gnl
selon lui l'élection dans la région sera
carrément un référendum dans la région
de saguenay lac saint jean un vote le
parti conservateur du québec ça va être
un votre projet gnl l'an dernier le bape
bureau d'audiences publiques sur
l'environnement avait estimé que les
risques du projet dépasse les avantages
en raison du manque d'acceptabilité
sociale des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et des retombées économiques de
courte durée mais avec la guerre en
ukraine éric duhaime avance que le
contexte a changé et quand vous me
demandez si le bape s'est trompé mais
oui c'est tromper la discussion semble
avoir changé un peu depuis quelques mois
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
sur le dos le rôle de ce genre
d'installation là pour aider la crise
énergétique en europe mais faut bien
comprendre que c'est incompatible avec
les objectifs de carboneutralité l'un
qui existe au canada tout de même si un
projet est soumis ottawa compte
l'étudient si des gens veulent ramener
un nouveau projet un projet différent
mais ça parle fera les étapes
réglementaires d'ailleurs dans une
déclaration gnl québec prétend pouvoir
soulager les pays européens qui
souffrent de la crise est née j'ai tic
en plus de remplacer des carburants plus
polluants des seulement dans quelques
années est à ce point si un seul des
cinq partis donc s'engage à y donner son
feu vert à l'issue de la campagne
électorale ici sébastien desrosiers
radio canada saguenay